hello everyone and welcome to a game
from the finals of defeated Women's
World Chess Championship it's again from
between Catarina lagna and when jin-joo
now a lager no defeated the Miriam was a
joker in the semi-finals to get into the
finals and when jin-joo has defeated
Alexander Castilla who after she dropped
out of the competition continued the
commenting with Alexandre Morrow's a
witch on the rest of the games so it's
in a lot of ways this game is similar to
what's going on over the board in the
constant versus Caruana match but in
other ways it's also very different as
the game is much crazier and the lines
in this game are really insane so before
we check out the actual game if you're
interested in who defeated who like the
entire you know three branching out I
will put a very nice link in the
description below to the chest 24
website where you can follow everything
and also a nice link to the official
feed a website where you can check out
on some of the photos here are only a
couple of photos from the official feed
a website here is a very nice photo of
Katarina also we have here a very nice
photo of the two of them and here are
very nice well not a close-up but I it's
the best I could find but there are a
couple of more photos under link in the
description below here pondering on the
position but they're being said let's
check it out then it's very interesting
as it features a similar line well it's
the same line until it's not that was
featured in Game five of the cross and
versus Caruana match so II for c5 we
have the Sicilian defense on the board a
night of 396 and Bishop to b5 again the
mesh MIDI Navarro SoLoMo attack
we have g6 castles of Bishop to g7 rook
to e1 and now II five and this is the
exact same position that was on the
board in the game five in corona versus
calls and match where Caruana surprised
Qasim with this immediate before but
here a lag no actually prepares it to
with a 3 a 3 it's a it serves as a
multi-purpose move it prepares B for so
will you definitely want to play it at
some point but also after this Bishop
retreats
it creates an outpost on a 2 for this
light square Bishop it's ok
we have tonight the G to e7 when Jim
prepares the castle and now comes Knight
to c3 if you go before immediately it
doesn't really do all that much black
can just ignore it and play nice to d4
attack your Bishop here and after Bishop
goes back now it's actually black who is
playing for some very nice development
and it's gonna be a very active game
from black so after night g7 Knights the
c3 and now comes Castle Bishop to c4 not
allowing Knights d4 to come with tempo
and now comes d6 we have d3 and here you
could develop with something like Bishop
to g4 but if you allow rush up to g5
then but White's the Bishop to g5 will
be somewhat better than your Bishop to
g4 here black can't really play f6 to
get rid of your bishop as this
light-square bishop is spinning the f7
pawn and you're gonna have to play h6 to
unpin at some point so Jew does it
immediately after d3 we have h6 not
allowing Bishop to g5 Knights the d5 and
now comes King to h7 and not allowing
any future pinning ideas now the king is
no longer on g8 and also it serves as an
additional protection to the h6 pawn in
the future ideas like Bishop to e3 Queen
d2 may be possible and then the h6 bone
will be an prize so came the night is
now on d5 it's it's an excellent Square
for tonight also if you ever want to
challenge blacks very strong center you
will have to play C 3 and d 4 at some
point so it does make sense to get the
night off of c3 c3 is played now we have
f5 and here there are ideas possible
here but lagna goes for the most
exciting one he captures an f5 here you
can play Knight captures on f5 you can
play Bishop captures on f5 but here is
the most important thing about this game
so as this is a match Katarina is one
point in the lead and this is the final
game of their match unless avenging
manages to win this game
but basically Katarina lagna only needs
a draw with the white pieces to become
the world's champion and it's a very
tough game for black so usually you
would want to capture this with the
bishop or would deny it but as a black
really has to win this game G characters
on f5 is played and this is the one of
the more critical moments in the game as
you can get because here the real
question is can white go Knight to g5
and if white can do this then definitely
you're either going to draw or win but
if you if you can't do this then you're
in a lot of trouble so what's the idea
behind Knight to g5 the idea is if you
go Knight to g5 notice that the bishop
on c4 is still kind of controlling the
g8 Square so now you're in check if you
capture the knight to then Queen h5
check King moves to g8 and now Knight
captures an e7 delivers a double check
but also notice that the black king is
now in checkmate on the other hand if
you don't move the King if you block
let's say bishop here then you can play
Bishop captures and g5 there's the
threat of Queen captures on h6 and after
the knight - defends this well you're
just gonna lose the Queen but there's no
other way to defend checkmate so here
white is simply winning but there's much
more to this position after Knight to g5
check black doesn't have to of course
capture the knight black can go King to
h8 if King to h8 is played then you get
Queen to h5 threatening Knight to f7
check but now Knight captures on d5
Bishop captures and Queen to f6 now
controlling the f7 Square and although
you can play Knight to f7 check the king
will then be able to come to h7 as the
knight will no longer be controlling it
but here f4 will be a tremendous move
and it's very hard to decide how to
continue this with black if you capture
then Knight to f7 definitely is an idea
King h7 Bishop captures on a for now the
d6 pawn will fall and black will
eventually fall apart here and if you
don't open up the e-file other ideas
like well you can't really move any of
the pieces you can try and develop with
Bishop to d7 but then Knight to f3
the knight is now coming to h4 then to
g6 and it will be very hard to play this
with black but the biggest question of
this position is after Knight to g5
check not capture
tonight or going to h8 of course you
don't want to go here because then you
just lose the Queen
the real question behind this move is
what happens if King comes to g6 and
here of course lagna had to spend most
of her time calculating every possible
line after King to g6
so can you can you simply start
attacking well not really one of the
ideas that perhaps comes to mind is
Knight to f4 check so what happens here
of course if you capture the knight then
the knight comes to e6 with a double
check you win the Queen but if you
simply capture it yes you do open up the
e-file but there's no way to take
advantage of this and it seems very
unnatural that the black King is
actually quite safe on g6 while the
knight is controlling h7 and f7 there's
simply no way to continue the attack
black keeps an eye on this ecig square
so there's really no way to do it on the
other hand white only needs a draw and
she becomes the world chess champion so
what happens if Knight to f3 is played
simply bringing the knight back and now
if King repeats King gate 7 now you go
tonight back to g5 check King g6 neither
goes back and you repeat because you
only need a draw to become a world
champion the problem is after Knight to
g5 what happens if sorry about that
what happens if Knight g5 checking g6
and then what happens if Knight captures
if King to g6 then what do you what do
you really play here if you just go
Knight back to f3 black can capture on
d5 and then after Bishop characters is
it still a draw after King to h7 no not
so much
now after Knight to g5 check it's a bit
of a different story because now white
black can actually capture the knight
pawn captures and Queen to h5 now does
nothing because black can actually
defend the Queen is now also controlling
the g5 pawn and there's really no point
in capturing it you will just be down a
piece so there's really no good way to
continue this attack is if h4 simply
attacking the pin piece f4 now comes
black is defending and all is well for
black
so it seems like this was an excellent
move Knight to g5 but there is no actual
clear way of how do you win this so
Catarina Laguna decides not to do this
first before this always remains the
idea but now you want to play b5 and
kick this night away from c6 Zhu
immediately goes Knight to g6 and now
ideas like Knight g5 and are no longer
possible as the Queen is now also
guarding the g5 square H captures now
night Queen to h5 is pointless because
like we mentioned the g5 pawn is now
very well well protected after Knight to
g6 we have b5 kicking this night away
Knight to a5 attacking the bishop on c4
but as we already mentioned the bishop
has a very nice outpost on e2 and now
comes a Bishop to e6 a very nice
developing move attacks the knight but
also counters this very strong
light-square bishop on a2 and here you
could try something like well there
really aren't no good discovery aren't
any good discoveries the bishop on e6 is
unguarded but tonight to f6 check simply
runs into rook captures or Queen
captures and then the bishop on e6 is is
protected so here we have Queen - a for
attacking the knight here b6 protecting
the night and now comes Bishop to d2 you
wanna get this Bishop somehow into the
game so you can develop your rooks and
well keep on developing rook the g8 Jew
does have a semi-open G file so she
definitely plans to use it
rook a to d1 Queen to d7 and now comes
Knight to h4 and 9th to h4 is a move
that loses the game but it's not it's
not really like a super blunder but it's
more of a subtle blunder that when
someone tells you it's a blunder you
didn't realize how to take advantage of
it so here I'm actually telling you it's
a blunder so feel free to pause the
video here and try to take advantage of
this nice to h4 idea I will give you a
couple of seconds as usual for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are again an
excellent
solver of positions that never have
over the board and for those who just
want to enjoy the show the mood that was
not played in this game but it's not an
easy move to find is actually c4 would
see for you take away the bishops
protection of the knight on d5 but also
you take away the Queen's protection of
this night on h4 so it's really a
wonderful a wonderful idea
now after night chapters on g6 first you
will capture on d5 because this night
isn't protected at all
and now after D captures on c4 you
simply go back and now this is the
problem your knight on g6 is still under
attack
Knight to h4 you have Bishop to f6
attacking the knight you cannot protect
with g3 because the G G pawn would be
pinned the rook is spinning the Jeep on
you would have to move the knight Knight
to f3 and here comes the move you really
have to visualize to go into all of this
queen bees oops not Queen c7 but
actually Queen b7 and now there's really
not and nothing smart you can do this
Queen captures on f3 is a threat you
can't really move the knight because
then Queen captures and g2 would be the
threat of checkmate and there's really
no way to protect it
something like rook to e3 would be
messed with f4 simply attacking the rook
and now you will either go route d3 and
allow efore now it's simply a lost
position or you will try something like
Queen to c2 as f4 was played but after
you move the king let's say King to h8
you still have to move the rook you can
move it to e4 to prevent efore but now
comes the Bishop to a5 and again black
is winning so a very nice subtle idea
this c4 move Jew did not find it over
the board she played Bishop to h8 and
now we have Knight captures on g6 rook
captures on g6 and now Queen to h4
bringing the Queen both into the attack
but also in to help out with the defend
there's a lot of pressure here going on
against the h6 pawn ah but of course
jewel will double rooks on the G file
rook a to g8 and now we have g3 of
course you don't want a lot of real
captures on g2 and again you could
definitely stir some trouble by going c4
if c4 then Queen to e7 check
something you allow simply exchanging
queens and after roadblocks Queen
captures Bishop captures and then after
pawn captures on c4 white would be
somewhat better here
well blacks night is a bit misplaced
here you are up in material so not
interested in doing that
so instead Queen to f7 simply there's a
double attack against the d5 Knight and
now Queen to e7 doesn't really do all
that much for you you're not really
threatening to exchange Queens here
because the black will just ignore you
and capture a free knight on d5 now the
queen is no longer protected black is
definitely threatening to play Queen
captures on e7 and here after captures
captures captures and rook here you
would capture the room but then after
King captures you would actually have a
night a knight and the bishop for a rope
here so definitely would be not not
better but but much worse so white would
definitely have the upper hand here so
after Queen to f7 we have c4 Queen to e7
definitely was a possibility but not
played we have Bishop to f6 attacking
the Queen and h4 and now comes Knight
captures on f6 rook captures on f6 and
now F for not allowing black to play f4
and open up the position we have looked
the g4 attacking White Queen Queen to h3
and now rook F to g6 again doubling up
on the G file we have rope to f1 and now
comes Queen to g7 now this you can see
that aliens gun is fully loaded and
white is white has to make a move just
to show what the threat is if black if
white makes some sort of a silly move
like rook D to e one and then of course
the the threat is rook captures and g3
and after rook captures and G 3h captors
and g3 rook captures you lose the Queen
and the game captures captures and now
after the King moves well black is just
better but there's also a forced win
after Bishop to b7 there's really no way
to
and against this feel free to pause the
video here and try to find a way how to
proceed with white here how do you
prevent rook address on g3 and you know
it's not not a small task as the title
of video Women's World Chess Champion
depends on it so as usual I will give
you a couple of seconds so feel free to
go for it for those of you who were able
to do is congratulations you are an
excellent player and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show Queen to
h5 is the only move that actually saves
white because now rook captures and g3
doesn't work but it's not all that easy
to figure out why it doesn't work after
H captures rook captures on g3 King to
h2 and now comes rook to g2 check King
goes to h1 and now black still seems to
have this Bishop to c8 move which you
know Bishop to d7 would be a pretty
dangerous idea but now the real
defensive resource for white is actually
before and now the threat is if you go
Bishop to b7 white will play d5 and
close this diagonal forever so you can
allow this you have to play ECAP force
on d4 but then comes bishop to be one
and now you're preventing Bishop to b7
by actually threatening to capture an f5
if Bishop here then Bishop captures King
moves and now Queen to e8 check Queen
blocks Queen capture skin captures and
now even rope the g1 not allowing any
discoveries to be made as the rook and
g2 is also pin so it's pretty much a
double pin you would have to capture
here and then after King captures it's
basically white is up a whole rook so
after Bishop to be one you would not be
able to play Bishop to be seven because
of this threat
you would have to play something like
Queen to be seven but even that is not
enough now a white would have Queen to
f3 and now after Queen captures rook
captures rook has to move back and now
simply King moves and again if you are
up a whole rook so Queen to h5
definitely a wonderful move you just
have to get your queen out of h3 not to
allow this row characters and g3 to come
with an attack on your Queen and we've
just seen that ideas any active ideas
for
don't work and as soon as a white place
rook to f3 then any future plans against
the g3 pawn will simply not work but
here facing the aliens gun as you know
it is quite quite a dangerous structure
here Catarina had some six and a half
minutes on the clock and she played a
move that simply will not do
instead of Queen to h5 she played King
to h1 but now it's actually game over
because she she voluntarily put her King
on this diagonal and Joo simply played
Bishop to c8 also interesting even this
King to h1 move doesn't really help
white say white queen be protected after
real captures on g3 if H captures rook
after sin Queen to h5 still you get
Queen to b7 check now you would have to
block there's really nothing to do here
if you play King gauge to queen g2 will
be checkmate so after roblox rook
captures you would have to move the king
to prevent discoveries but still your
king is in the mating net queen f2
checkmate
but okay after King to h1 it's a it's a
very you know barbaric move when Jin
goes for the for the nicer one brush up
to see it now Bishop to b7 is of course
the threat we have Queen to h5 and now
Bishop to b7 check King to g1 but now
with the bishop already being and b7
it's a completely different story
rook captures pawn captures rook
captures King to have two and after rook
to g2 it was in this position that
Katarina lagna resigned the game so she
resigned because whatever she does at
least the force checkmate if King he won
then Queen g3 check roblox Queen
captures and if you go Queen King to e3
then of course you get Queen check
roadblocks and now pawn captures on f4
again with checkmate as the pawn here
prevents the King from escaping
despondent prevents the King from
escaping here and the rook is covering
the second rank so yeah after roof - G -
Katarina Allah resigned the game the
match is now tied they went in to tie
breaks and then thigh breaks out of the
four games the first two games were
drawn and then when
you managed to beat Katharina log no two
games in a row
and as of today when Jinju is the feeder
world's women champion so very you know
congratulations to her and we do have a
very nice photo here of dvorkovich
presenting both of them with prizes as
they are the finalists of this
competition I do not know who the
gentleman on the right is but I'm sure
some of you do so you know feel free to
also share in the comments so yeah there
you have it
as you can see definitely a lot of
fireworks on the board much more
fireworks than in the cross and versus
Caruana championship and it's really
really amazing that you know it's so
close but yet so far you you have the
white pieces and you just need a draw so
many opportunities present themselves
you know if for example if black didn't
have to win this game most likely in
that position that we've mentioned so
let me just go back real quick here
perhaps you know if this was just a
regular game perhaps it Bishop captures
or Knight captures will be played but
here you give white so many chances so
many options wide it really has to think
figure out everything goes into time
trouble and then you know finally after
facing valley hands gun blunders the
game and you know yeah ends up losing
any chances of of becoming a world
champion so really really crazy stuff
but yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Robert
Atkinson f1 winch Intel virus Chris
genes
Carlos graça and only marine and for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content either we're gonna
check something in the morning if I will
have time but if not continuing with
Coulson versus copper one on game 11
thank you all and I will see you soon